Well, hi there.
My name is Nick Butcher.
I'm a designer and developer on
the Google Developer Relations
team.
I'm based out of London,
but I'm here right now
in I/O in the Moscone
center, soaking up
the amazing atmosphere, the
carnival playground atmosphere,
which I think you could call it.
So it's great to be here.
This is my fourth I/O,
I think, I've been to.
And it's actually quite
fun for me this year,
because I'm not speaking.
So I haven't had
the massive amount
of nerves and preparation
to get my talk out there.
But I've actually been spending
all my time in the design area.
There's a whole area just to
talk about design and share
material design insights.
And I've just been meeting
a whole bunch of developers.
We've been looking at
apps, giving them feedback,
chatting about
their apps, how we
can make it cooler, how
we could make it better,
how we could make it fit
better into the platform.
So I've had a great
I/O. Just have
met a whole ton of
people, had a whole lot
of great conversations.
I've been super excited
about a bunch of the stuff
we've shared.
We've opened up-- just in
the last couple of days,
there's a tsunami, an
avalanche of content.
I know it's hard to keep up.
But some of the highlights
for me-- obviously, we
talked about Android
M for the first time,
so some really, really great
stuff for users in there.
I think Permissions are a
big, big fundamental change.
For me, with design
being core to my heart,
I think the UX of how you ask
for those permission changes is
going to be really interesting
and something that we
need to look at and learn from.
I'm really excited about all
the amazing stuff going on
with material design.
So Matias Duarte gave
a great talk last night
where he shared some numbers
about how things have gone,
and how many apps
have embraced it,
and how they found that it has
helped them improve their app.
For the developer
me, I'm also really
excited about the new design
support library, which
is going to make it so much
easier for Android developers
out there to implement
all these material design
components in a consistent way.
So that's really,
really exciting.
But it's really, really great
to be back here at Moscone
and soak it all up,
meet the developers.
It's a very different
look and feel this year.
Hopefully you can see
there's a kind of rustic--
there's lots of cardboard
and corrugated iron.
It feels a lot more friendly.
Everyone's just really
enjoying it, hanging out,
chatting to each other,
lots of great conversations.
For those of you who
couldn't make it here, sorry.
I hope you can make it one year.
It's an amazing
experience, do try.
But hopefully you
can follow along
with a lot of the content on
our Google Developers YouTube
channel.
What else should I say?
Oh, you should also
definitely, definitely
check out the brand new website
we launched for Google Design.
So if you go to
google.com/design,
there's a shiny new website
where we've added a whole bunch
of new content.
Some of my favorite stuff
is a wonderful video
about how we made
material design, how
to work with your brand and
material design, some really,
really great content there.
But yeah, thanks very
much for joining me here
on the Moscone floor.
I'm Nick Butcher, and yeah,
go check out google.com/design
and do subscribe to the Google
Developers channel to keep up
with all the awesome
content coming out of I/O.
[MUSIC PLAYING]